[Music]
hello guys and welcome to another video
in this video i'm going to do a
breakdown of a knight of ram trailer
which has apparently leaked also in this
video i will give you my opinion on if i
think this is real or not but away let's
get straight into the breakdown so the
trailer starts off with the lucasfilm
logo and then we cut to a shot where we
see mustapha in the background you can
actually see what looks to be raiders
castle moving on we see a shot of a tie
fighter chase in the next swing no shots
have been fired from the thai fighter
he's just merely chasing the x-wing at
this point one thing to point out is the
sound effects
[Music]
now the sound effects of the um tie
fighter and xbox make me believe this
could be fake because the sound effects
user the first sound effects you'll find
when you search up style with sound
effects for x-wings and tie fighters
which are really old and outdated ones
so the shop hands up to the top of the
tie fighter and we see what looks to be
a knight of red that emerges on top of
it now i believe this knight of ren we
actually haven't seen before or
potentially it's a night of rain that
we've seen before but they're doing in a
different look here he then ignites his
lightsaber and jumps off the tie fighter
to then land on top of the x-wing and
then slice it with his lightsaber we
then cut to a very cool shot of the
wreckage of the x-wing it's a really
fantastic environment of particles and
everything is just really well done the
camera then pans up to reveal knight of
ren who says two lightsabers as he
ignites both of them now i gotta say
this shot in particular um it looks very
like video game like clearly this whole
thing has been animated as opposed to
live action but you know it's been
really well done everything here just
looks extremely well done definitely
done by a professional but i do believe
this is actually a fake and if it is
fake it's probably one of the best fakes
i've seen at the end here you can
actually see the knight of ren himself
judah on top of the x-wing his character
goes side to side now what i think makes
it even more likely that it's a fake at
the end of the trailer it's his knights
of wren a star wars story now lucasfilm
and disney have kind of stopped using a
star wars story for the title the
upcoming kenobi tv show doesn't say a
star wars story now this night of ram
project is actually meant to be released
on disney plus so it makes sense that
they just start using them again but
then they don't decide to use it for
kenobi as well or the upcoming and or tv
show also another thing to point out
that on the bottom of the screen you can
see
2021 and we're in 2022 now and last year
i don't remember any knights of rand
projects release it on disney plus now
as i mentioned before it looks like a
video game cinematic and this is
released on disney plus so we can
completely rule out that it's not
releasing as a video game so with all
these points i've mentioned in my
opinion i do believe this is fake also
this has been out for over a day now and
it still hasn't been removed by
lucasfilm and disney if this was real i
would imagine it probably would have
been removed already by disney they're
pretty quick to act on these type of
things anyway i thought this was
extremely well done and i hope the
creative list actually releases it on
his channel without it being filmed
through a phone because you know i love
to watch it without it being super
compressed and stuff like that anyway
with that out of the way tell me in the
comment section below if you think this
is real or fake and would you like to
see a knight of ren tv show movie also
if you haven't already please like and
subscribe to show your support thanks
for watching guys